he and i have traveled the world [ __ ]
extensively so here's my question as
somebody who knows what addiction looks
like is familiar with it
do you feel
this country
is more addictive than other countries i
i my feeling is america the american
sensibility like you know [ __ ] uh the
pursuit of happiness which is [ __ ]
right there um in in the founding one of
the founding documents of this country
i think
it's a very uniquely american ideal
to have something that's good and then
want to make it better and make it last
all the time
right like that there was an amount of
craving that buddhism talks about what
is it explain whatever your situation is
you you want to improve it if you're in
pain you want the pain to end if you
feel good you want the the good feeling
to be intensified and to last longer yes
so wait is that so so that's what it
would say about to say that they're like
don't do that
you just have to to not let your craving
uh you know
dictate your life that really that
happiness is gonna come not from uh
improving your situation but rather
accepting what is
you know sort of uh being in the present
and and accepting the moment of as it is
and not getting too caught up in
improving the the moment is it wrong to
want
something good
to happen as frequently as possible
i i don't think so i don't think so but
what where the the line i think lives
and i think you're really really uh on
to something by pointing to america as
being problematic is that and i love the
country don't get me wrong but it's of
course we are when it but america is not
better all the time and it's like right
there's always something better than
this like i don't think about it we're
marketed to on a regular basis the whole
world is but america is [ __ ]
exceptional and it's making you believe
that like
a [ __ ] iphone's not good enough you
gotta get a new one right so like seems
to be more addiction in america versus
like elsewhere i think yeah i think so
and i think that america is more caught
up in the pursuit of pleasure yes than
the pursuit of happiness you're
absolutely right i think you nailed it
right there mine is between pleasure and
happiness and now dude i'm gonna i'm
gonna tell you this crazy thing
um i don't think i've ever said it on
this podcast but i i didn't want to kids
i didn't want to have kids for for a
whole bunch of reasons right um
genetically like every leaf on my family
tree
is like suffers from
alcoholism
addiction gambling suicide you know my
mom's side of the family literally every
[ __ ] person that we can identify
through the family tree is all dead from
that [ __ ] you know like i'm the first
one to to break the curse right so
passing on the genetics is is
problematic and then there's
the
the this whole dynamic of the rich
getting richer and the poor getting
poorer which just stopped being [ __ ]
funny you know like
it's
we're really at a point where it's
[ __ ] up i mean
and i said this to my buddy i've one
friend i've known since we were both
nine years old in fourth grade his name
is abdullah and um
his family's from sudan he's devout
muslim i used to
spend so much time at his house and i
would pray to mecca with abdullah when
we were just kids
and uh we graduated high school together
he went on to brown university got a 4.0
then he went to cornell medical school
then he became a pediatric surgeon at
the mayo clinic has since invented ways
of operating on
babies that are still in the womb and
have not yet been born
and he's the most like just unbelievably
like
wonderful person he's such a gift to the
world and our paths are very different
but we've kept in touch forever now i
was talking to abdullah
probably 10 years ago now and i'm saying
i don't want to have kids
he's shocked
and i said dude abdullah for our parents
um
a
university diploma meant placement in a
career of your choosing for us not so
much for our kids it means student debt
it's a nightmare like the the the
dwindling opportunity in the world is
really uh upsetting to me and i don't
want it on my conscience that i created
a human being to to struggle and suffer
right abdullah looks at me like i'm
[ __ ]
out of my mind and he says
in africa
where with all of the
the
famine the poverty the disease
do you think
people are less happy
now my god
response my initial reaction is well
[ __ ] yeah they're less happy
but
he he tells me they're not and and and i
understand intellectually what
abdullah's point is which is that you
can
strip
people of of their health of their their
their ability to eat of their you know
their shelter everything but you cannot
strip a human being of their capacity to
love another and that is what true
happiness is derived from is
loving another and so
it's pretty heavy
i went ahead and got the vasectomy
like all right abdullah i hear you
but to a point
i'm just going to hedge my best
yeah he saved his sperm just in case you
did you save a violence
i i think i would be a reasonably good
father but i just like uh
there's the genetics there's the
societal concerns and then there's just
the fact that i'm a kid and i'm always
going to be a kid the best dad in the
world jason muse hands down best father
i've ever seen jason muse was a better
father than i was
and i wish he had had a kid before i'd
had a kid because i would have seen how
you should do it
um you know there was a guy who a lot of
people wrote off as a [ __ ] mess and
an addict and [ __ ] like that he's been
clean and sober now for over 10 years 12
years
and hands down the best father i've ever
seen that kid
like
is entertained
by a one-man show
throughout her whole [ __ ] life a show
that most people like here's some money
do some funny [ __ ] and whatnot and she
gets it for free all the time you'd be
the same kind of [ __ ] father i i
don't doubt it uh and i appreciate that
i think that like
i i have a profound
respect for the idea of parenthood and
um
i think a lot of people don't i think
that clip was awesome but not as awesome
as my new book a hard kick in the nuts
what i've learned from a lifetime of
terrible decisions which is out
september 27th and if you pre-order it
right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not going to waste your time
because i'm proven dude new york times
best seller my first book's five star
rated on amazon and i have no doubt this
one will be two so get the autographed
copy right now by pre-ordering it at
stevo.com
yeah dude